are you guys doing today good before we
get started the only reason I get to
collider gets to be at Toronto and cover
the film festival is because of house of
Aurora which is where you're at and they
are I really want to thank them for
being a great sponsor and partner and
being able to do stuff here because it's
really expensive to cover TIFF in case
you didn't know right you know you have
the Facebook money so I got to see the
first four episodes and really really
dug it and if I had had access to the
first next six I would have immediately
continued so that's my you know the best
thing I can say talk a little bit about
most people everyone watching this won't
have seen it yet I'm gonna air it right
before it comes out talk a little bit
about what the show is about and let's
just start with that
that's a me question because I made I
created it and we all made it together
um so sorry for your loss is about Lee
played by our Elizabeth Olsen who is a
young woman whose husband dies very
unexpectedly and it's very much about
how she has to put the pieces of her
life back together and figure out how
she's going to survive and move forward
in the face of this impossible thing I'm
curious when you go in to like pitch the
show to Facebook and you're going with
it I think a lot of people nowadays are
looking for multiple seasons and you
know they're not thinking of it it's
like a one-off it's very hard to do that
so when you have that like initial pitch
are you sort of saying hey I have an
idea for like three years or I have an
idea for this or is it sort of like you
know what I mean what is that
conversation like yeah absolutely I mean
I think typically now you do put
together a document it could be anywhere
from I think five pages to fifty pages
I've seen some pretty insane I think
Battlestar Galactica had like an insane
Bible that they came in with but
basically you are saying this is what I
see happening in the first season this
is what I see happening in future
seasons laying
not only individual stories but real
arcs and overall journeys and I mean
look I wrote this thing four and a half
years ago I've had time to think about
it and I'm all over who these people are
and where they're gonna go so it feels
like this all feels like like when we
went into Facebook I'm like well I've
I've studied for this test for four
years I am prepared to take and prepare
to turn in this final exam as it were
sure how did you - because you're
executive producing this if I'm not
mistaken how did you guys first hook up
through Robyn Schwartz who's our
executive producer with big beech and
she sent it over to me after reading kit
script and then I was I loved Lea I
loved the character I also liked playing
people that are initially kind of hard
to like because I liked defending them
and finding empathy and I also thought
that there is this was like a little
hole and a gap storytelling where you
don't really have too many stories that
are about an authentic expression of
grief and loss we have a lot of
literature so much literature I think it
actually Robin even said it has its own
Barnes & Noble they have a grief memoirs
yes and I believe and it's a tone
section yeah we don't talk about it and
it's not part of really too much film or
television in a real struggling way and
so we hooked up and we did the pitches
together and we then grabbed then we
started assembling a team we went to
James we knew we wanted him to come on
as a director because we all loved how
he he films things at being such a fly
on the wall and you just feel like
you're inside the world with all the
characters and he has such a sensitivity
about how he shoots his own films and we
were really lucky that it was this this
like hizmet connection also with the
subject matter her in such a deep way
well talk a little bit about what was it
about the story and what was it about
the story that appealed to you and said
I want to do this yeah I mean you know
it was it was the script and I was a big
fan of Lizzie's as well but I mean I was
I was moved that was the biggest thing
and I you know I hadn't read anything
before that dealt that dealt with sort
of
brief trauma and recovery but that
wasn't solely about death it was about
life that was ultimately life-affirming
and about sort of resiliency and the
relationships that we sort of create as
we try to move forward and it reminded
me in some ways I mean I'd done the
first couple episodes of master of none
and this sort of reminded me of that as
well where there was clearly a you know
a very heavy just dark version of this
that would be an hour long but this in a
half hour with humor took on issues in a
way that I had just never seen before
that I felt like you know that could
open up you know they had the potential
to make an audience go on a journey but
they might not think they would go on
and do it with unexpected lightness and
and and hopefulness talk a little bit
about how you actually got involved and
we'll start with that sure yeah I am I
had worked with James before and why I'm
not Asian
you know and about us and yeah yeah is
that true yeah can you really tell a
chemistry read on skype pops off the
screen yeah that's pretty awesome and
then yeah we Skype again I was in
Colorado I have like a room with my
phone it's really really intense but uh
I just wanted a work of James again and
like this I read the script I looks
great and I've seen Lizzie's work all
over so I was a huge fan of her so I got
to do this one of the things about your
character is that it's really one of the
things I love when you can do an
extended storyline is you can really get
into Explorer character and really go
deep and what I really enjoyed about
your character is that you know you're
dealing with depression and you're
dealing with real life stuff and it's as
you said stuff that you generally don't
see you know one portrays his stuff
because it's it's tough and it's tough
to talk about because so talk a little
bit getting a play a character like that
with so many layers oh yeah it was I
mean it might sound strange Steven but
it's kind of a gift in a way cuz I I
feel like I learned a lot about people
in my own life and became a lot more
compassionate so their struggles because
I was just kind of oblivious before
but I and and in the process of that I
also learned a lot of on my own self and
like my own habits and like my own like
oh I should probably investigate that's
a little bit more especially doing like
Episode five I was like oh I do that
anyway I'm curious about Episode five
because I have not seen it and episode
four ends on a little bit about what we
call a cliffhanger alright alright one
of my my favorite episodes because it is
it is a shift in perspective and I think
that is why we're releasing the first
four because there is a big shift that
happens and I think the way KITT has has
unfolded and told the story about loss
and grief and depression
it's like them and not me of it you know
it's like the stuff that's like not
fancy it's not it's not like exaggerated
there's like a mundane quality to
depression and there's just certain
things that I love so much about
actually getting to capture that as
opposed to making it super dramatic just
for purpose of story and I think that's
it's a risk and I and I really I
appreciate that specifically in episode
5 but never September 25th or something
so you guys made this with Facebook and
this is one of their first releases if
not their first release did it say the
do's and do nots on the piece of paper
that's proprietary information I think
we've got to keep a little bit close to
the vest why I am curious though what
was it like working with them because
they are a new I mean they're a huge
company but this is they're you know
they're pushing into original content
and I'm curious what was it like with
like the note-taking process and being a
collaborator with Facebook
it was awesome they want to make the
same show they wanted to make the same
show we wanted to make and that's the
most you can ask for in a home is they
wanted us to be exactly the creature we
were they weren't trying to make us
funnier they weren't trying to make us
soapier they just wanted us to be the
show that we were and that was really
validating and exciting so um their
notes were I think very geared towards
um oftentimes clarity making sure that
we were always really staying true to
the characters and really creating that
that wonderful illusion I call it be a
ghost in the room where it doesn't feel
like characters are espousing exposition
for the audience's benefit but really
you just feel like you're spying on real
people interacting in a way they really
would know they were their notes were
organic Jermaine I loved them about the
editing process because and very
involved in that Mamadou there was one
day where he like poked his head in to
say goodbye I'm leaving or something and
then you saw that we were editing an
episode you were on screen you're like
the timeline right that Kelly found out
and then Kelly shortly thereafter was in
the bay I think we call them editing
classes a future date we did have you
know two fantastic editors Darren Darren
Navarro who I've worked with before who
also works at William Friedkin and it
worked on I love dick and then Hilda
rasoolullah who'd worked on transparent
as well so we had one task what I'm
curious about because ultimately the
editing process is the final rewrite so
I'm curious what did you learn in the
editing room that maybe wasn't on the
page and did you do any sort of
screenings for like friends and family
and did those screenings impact the
finished product
yeah yeah I mean I think there's you
know you inevitably have have blind
spots sometimes while you're making
things and I think you know is really
great I mean we the show goes sort of
there's past and present you're sort of
weaving those two in and out and in some
cases you're I mean the scripts were
great but in some cases you're making
minor rewrites and then when we were
showing the episodes we would screen
them two at a time for groups of friends
family and you know we gotten incredible
notes and we also saw like people were
laughing in places or crying and you
know yeah I was thinking of the pilot
episode in particular the flashbacks and
on the page the plotting in the sequence
of them made a lot of sense but then
once we got into our initial cuts we
were realizing that um it was it was
feeling a little murky and so it really
was there was some restructuring
reordering um a little bit of ADR
a smidge of ADR I mean we were realizing
oh wait we never saved this character's
name we probably should get that like at
some point in the first episode um but
that was and again that was Darrin in
episode 1 and then Darren did the odd
episodes Hilda did the even episodes but
they really presented us really
wonderful cuts I had been warned ahead
of time like don't don't take the first
cut like to personally don't get too
worried like it all gets fixed but they
turned in really beautiful cuts so it
was I was like this is amazing like I
love these first cuts and we just made
them better and better from there and as
an actor I've like I I think with Taylor
Sheridan he would show me an early edit
and then I'll know there was
specifically a scene where I said I
remember something better can we please
go back to whatever you guys left on the
floor and that's what was interesting
about being a part of this process from
like a producer side as I would see a
take and I'd be like now I'm gonna go
watch dailies of this scene because I
think that there is something else that
I that I think we should use instead and
I'd like submit my request being an
executive producer
yeah and Pharaon performance which is
really which was we I mean I've been I
feel like I've I've never watched myself
more in my entire life and that's a very
weird feeling because you you eventually
feel nothing
but a question for you too often when I
speak to actors they talk about the
toughest thing is figuring out the first
thing about the character or sort of
figure out you know what I mean like
breaking getting breaking in and
figuring out the character talked a
little bit about how you the first thing
you did to get ready and just preparing
for these roles the thing that I usually
like to go into is like usually there's
like the full script and then there's a
history there so I'm like okay this
character says this about him there's
all these facts I can gather well
there's not a lot of fact once gripped
and they're like you know they're
flashbacks in like you know kind of out
of orders like wait what what else so it
kind of had a new approach to it which
was scary for me but also made me a even
more reliant on Lizzie but thank God
it's easy easier than it would have been
yeah I just kind of like relied on James
and Lizzie does kind of help me guide me
like where I needed to be because the
scenes were beautifully written but I
was like wait where is this coming from
who's this why is he there's a reason
for this I don't know what it is I
remember telling you facts for me it was
I mean the funny thing was is it we I
read the script three summers ago and we
pitched for six months or something and
we developed it and then we moved it
around and like so there I already felt
very connected to her about it comes to
the actual mentality and cyclical nature
of how your mind obsesses over grief we
would always reference here of magical
thinking and I read it when we were not
in prep at all and then I would reread
it while we were working and right
before working and I just think Joan
Didion creates such a
cific vivid depiction of like what
exactly was going through her head the
moment she lost her husband and the
obsessive nature of holding on to
memories and trying to member every
single detail so that person ever dies
in your memory as well as physically and
so that that was just kind of like a
nice insight tint for me everyone has
been coming in everyone has been coming
in everyone has been coming through the
studio we've been playing get to know
your TIF attendee we'll find out in 30
seconds what TV show would you love to
guest spot on what TV show would you
love to guest right and what TV show
would you love to guest direct fleabag
second season that's good your heart you
can like get it get creative a show from
yesteryear I don't think watches a lot
of TV the only thing that's coming to
mind the Seinfeld I'm gonna be so mad
everything so when they do reboot
Seinfeld to be the new Kramer everything
I'd like to work on is I would love to
be a part of Atlanta I love that entire
cast so much and they're all short films
basically to me and I think they're just
that to me was one of my favorite
seasons I watched season 2 oh it's
incredible it's mind-blowing yeah yeah I
completely agree my answer in say
Atlanta thrown
your spot I love the good place with the
fire of a thousand suns and so just to
just to be a fly on the wall I would be
the writer's assistant I would get them
lunch if I could just like sit during
the afternoon and listen to them scheme
and dream yeah I would have said Atlanta
but there he said it's also Barry had so
many long conversations while working
about Barry's telling James how much I
love succession and his and his response
was but you haven't watched Barry yet
just you wait when the Emmys come and
Barry wins everything and you haven't
seen it I'm being subsidized by Mary do
you have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film my favorite probably is your name I
think we phenomenal phenomenal by the
way if you haven't seen your name it
really is incredible it's one of the
best movies I've seen in a decade that's
beautiful well Return to Oz terrified
needs a child and it's still like
terrifies me and fascinates me I don't
think I'll ever truly understand that
film and I like that feeling how did I
miss that
oh no watch that movie as an adult is is
beyond disturbing and then as a child
you're kind of like what did you think
of that like being elected having the
electric shock therapy on a little girl
what did you think of that as a child
900 heads and yes Oh what are your
feelings return Oz it's brilliant you
should see children of men or so
Lloris okay what film scared you as a
kid besides return to us Dark Crystal I
think like all their like weird Jim
Henson stuff terrified me The Exorcist
the thing that I remember being scared
of was the beginning of Beethoven at the
pound I love scary movies as a kid I
loved being scared Ernest scared stupid
I loved although also fantasy sci fi how
about mom and dad save the world anyone
seen that family special one of our
favorites for each of you do you collect
anything refrigerator magnets I like I
like putting stuff in my refrigerator
and that requires magnets so I've got
like 30 I think a growing collection
I've never been emotionally attached to
anything I've always tried like even as
a little girl I like tried to become
emotionally attached like a stuffed
animal and I never cared so I don't
collect things
yeah I might have a toy book books and
movies I'm sort of a hoarder my DVD
collection do you own any movie or TV
show props yeah I own something from
this show there's a there's a five but
there's a this is I'm gonna get my voice
I don't know whatever I think is
anything there is a scene in Matt's
classroom and they're our wonderful set
decorator and production design team
created this runner of all these classic
books like it's like ticker tape that
lines the walls I just loved it and they
and they gave it to me so I haven't put
it up did you borrow it or they gave it
to you they gave it to me they said they
could they were confident if they could
you know they could print things on
paper again that they felt that they
could give it to me know have an ashtray
from Martha Marcy May Marlene that Sean
Durkin gave me one
and I it's a little sailboat glass
sailboat they like the backing for my
seat from unicorn store that I always
were a little because it's really
sparkly what TV show have you watched
all the way through more than once I'm
going through Game of Thrones for the
second time right now I'm on season 7
thank you also known as my favorite show
on TV like everybody else I've probably
seen Cowboy Bebop yeah oh yeah can we
bebop the best show that's ever existed
a fire and seen it maybe sometimes at
least seen freaks and geeks like four or
five times kids I feel like I've seen
every episode of Green Acres like five
times I need to do a follow-up on anime
with this guy right here
so you've seen Robo tech then I have him
Steven really no you should watch the
Macra saga from back in the 80s amazing
it is yeah I've never seen it um see
he's gonna watch something maybe it's
anime you don't like it I'm familiar I
just know it's hot right what's the
background photo on your phone it's so
it's well it's like a like an oil
painting of walking to Phoenix in her
[Laughter]
movies my best friend's little sister is
an artist and it's um like an ink on
plastic weird black white grey kind of
depressing image that I really love and
it's calming my kids pretending to be
cats
I'm really I got to be honest I am
shocked it's not Barry getting deleted
later interframe it's the factory
setting I'm so embarrassed it's just I
never put a background photo up you
don't have you seen a movie more which
movie have you seen more than 20 times
Wizard of Oz First Wives Club Annie Hall
Star Wars can you imagine
la-dee-da that's a we how many times did
you see her scared stupid though no I
mean safely twenty-eight probably Lion
King okay meeting the beasts beating the
beasts sorry that's why I mean anything
that involves animation yeah right I'm a
big it doesn't matter I'm gonna stop
there because you guys gotta go to your
next interview but I really I really
mean it when I say congratulations on
the show and especially being part of
tiff you know it's it's an amazing again
thank you to House of Aurora for having
us and thank you so much thank you so
much
[Music]